bonjour Claude Raynal merci beaucoup
d'être invité de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure
sénateur socialiste de la Haute-Garonne
vous présidez la commission des finances
et vous présiderez la commission
d'enquête sénatoriales sur le fond
Marianne on va bien sûr longuement
parler dans quelques instants mais
d'abord l'actualité c'est donc Gabriel
Attal qui a dévoilé les grandes lignes
de son plan de lutte contre la fraude
fiscale et le présentera officiellement
aujourd'hui il cite clairement les Ultra
riches et les multinationales hausse de
25% des contrôles fiscaux sur les gros
patrimoine contrôle fiscaux tous les
deux ans pour les plus grandes
entreprises vous saluez ce plan
contre la fraude de manière générale que
soit fiscale qu'elle soit douanières
éventuellement pour une toute petite
part sociale d'ailleurs j'observe que le
ministre ne met plus l'accent sur la
fraude sociale je pense que il a compris
que c'était pas là qui était l'enjeu
financièrement
tout ça si vous voulez il y a la faute
fiscale il y a la fraude douanière voilà
et marginalement et il y a des éléments
à regarder sur la fraude sociale voilà
donc
un montant en tout cas voilà dans
l'esprit des gens ça compte comme toutes
les fraudes de manière générale donc un
plan contre les fraudes de manière
générale c'est un plan
utile si l'atteint ses objectifs il y a
eu déjà des améliorations dans les
dernières années il faut le reconnaître
donc on peut aller encore plus loin tant
mieux
quand il dit chaque fraude est grave
mais celle des plus puissants est
impardonnable c'est bien qu'une tienne
ce genre de discours pour vous
je pense que c'est il y a un fond qui
est tout à fait vrai je pense que quand
on est ultra riche quand on a des
multinationales qui font d'énormes
bénéfices bon chercher à rogner la
participation finalement au financement
commun de la société je crois que ça
peut être dénoncé oui dans ces termes
pour les fraudeurs les plus graves
Gabriel Attal dit qu'il réfléchit à une
sanction d'indignité fiscale et civique
privation de réduction d'impôts droit de
vote privation temporaire du droit de
vote et il veut que les condamnations
pour faute fiscale s'accompagnent de
travaux d'intérêt général il dit en plus
de payer son amende le gros fraudeur
fiscal ira repeindre le centre des
impôts ce sont des bonnes mesures
le ministre parle avec ces mots et avec
ses exemples voilà mais des travaux
d'intérêt généraux pour des grands
patrons industriels j'attends de voir si
par exemple des grands patrons
industriels étaient touchés bien entendu
pas mais si c'était le cas de là aller
voir peindre quelque chose en ville je
suis pas tout à fait convaincu que
l'argument porte
je pensais que c'est pas réaliste vous
pensez que c'est pas une bonne chose à
sortir ses peines en plus des amendes de
sortir ces peines de privation de droits
civiques ou aucun problème j'étais sur
les TIG voilà qui me paraissait bon une
vision amusante de dire les choses voilà
autre sujet c'était Emmanuel Macron qui
a rendu hommage à Jean Moulin et à la
résistance hier à la prison Montluc à
Lyon ou des milliers de personnes ont
manifesté à Lyon mais gardé à bonne
distance du chef de l'État c'est
important pour vous de manifester le 8
mai jour où Emmanuel Macron célébrait la
résistance d'abord le sujet vient du
président de la République partout il va
il crée effectivement un problème d'une
certaine façon il ne peut plus se
déplacer comme il le souhaiterait comme
il le voudrait et s'il y a cette
situation c'est d'abord de son fait
c'est à dire que une incapacité
finalement à gérer des politiques
publiques en
s'entourant des avis en faisant
participer la population en faisant
accepter ces mesures et en travaillant
avec les syndicats voilà nous trompons
pas de sujet c'est ça le sujet
mais ça veut dire quoi que le problème
c'est Emmanuel Macron qu'il est isolé
qui peut plus réformer selon vous pour
l'instant c'est ce qu'il montre en tout
cas puisque nous n'avons pas un agenda
législatif considérable au Sénat en tout
cas actuellement alors que nous
pourrions avoir quelques textes
Elisabeth Bank va recevoir les syndicats
la semaine prochaine il faut tourner la
page de la réforme des retraites pour
vous
alors tourner la page c'est pas le bon
mot ce qui est sûr c'est que j'approuve
la position des syndicats les syndicats
ils ont un rôle général et permanent de
représentants des salariés et il doit si
elle leur fonction négocier alors
négocier dans les entreprises d'abord et
puis éventuellement négocier d'un
nouveau avantage avec ou nouvelle
propositions avec le gouvernement c'est
leur rôle et donc à un moment donné il
faut bien qu'il retrouve le rôle naturel
ça n'enlève rien me semble-t-il à la
défiance qui aujourd'hui
est épousé les syndicats qui appellent
les parlementaires à voter la loi
d'abrogation le 8 juin prochain à
l'Assemblée loi de progression de la
retraite à 64 ans est-ce que ça c'est
leur rôle
il y a toujours comment dire un
empiètement entre le politique et le
syndicat chacun essaie de rester dans
son rôle mais en même temps on est sur
un sujet qui est majeur les syndicats
font valoir leur position ils disent si
on était à l'Assemblée après tout à
l'Assemblée on a des représentants du
peuple ça pourrait être aussi les
représentants du coup d'ailleurs il y en
a eu et il y en a peut-être actuellement
à l'Assemblée nationale et donc bon
voilà c'est un message mais après la
décision appartient bien sûr au
parlementaire vous souhaitez que ce
texte si toutefois il est voté le 8 juin
à l'Assemblée vous pensez qu'il sera
voté d'ailleurs
très sincèrement je n'en sais rien je
vais le regarder je le souhaite oui
c'est pour vous si il est voté il faut
qu'il soit repris rapidement au Sénat
bien sûr c'est la logique la logique
même des institutions
les groupes de gauche en tout cas ce
cesseront de cette opportunité si elle
est posée en plus c'est manifestations à
Lyon il y a une action qui a fait un
petit peu polémique hier devant le siège
du de renaissance le parti de la
majorité présidentielle des militants de
la CGT et des membres de la France
insoumise ont manifesté avec des mots
repris par un conseiller régional
insoumis d'Île-de-France Louis XVI on
l'a décapité Macron on peut recommencer
est-ce que vous souhaitez vous condamner
c'est pas ses propos aujourd'hui avec
les tweets avec les réseaux sociaux on a
tout de suite on vous dévère sans arrêt
des phrases qui sans être sortis de leur
contexte en tout cas peuvent apparaître
paraît même choquantes voilà bon c'est
ainsi je pense que ce type de propos il
s'en est tenu de tout temps simplement à
l'époque les réseaux sociaux il y avait
pas les réseaux sociaux pour le envoyer
c'est une image bons réseaux sociaux
c'est pas un appel à la violence pour
vous de dire ça comme ça ou alors vous
vous allez nous dire comment de la
Révolution française il y avait des
appels à la violence c'est supportable
donc elle est que cette révolution
française finalement a fait que le roi
n'était n'est plus là bon en fait la
révolution
garder en tout en toute circonstances
voilà on va parler de l'actualité du
Sénat et votre commission des finances
va donc se constituer en commission
d'enquête sur le fond Marianne on fait
le point sur ce dossier avec notre
journaliste parlementaire Alex tout ça
[Musique]
bonjour Yann bonjour Claude rénal
bonjour
sa commission d'enquête sur l'affaire du
fond Marianne déjà rappelez-nous en quoi
consiste cette affaire alors le fond
Marianne est un fond gouvernemental
lancé en 2021 après l'assassinat de
Samuel Paty l'objectif de ce fond
c'était de promouvoir des contenus sur
Internet pour lutter contre la
radicalisation se font Marianne il était
doté de 2,5 millions d'euros 17
associations ont été sélectionnées et en
ont bénéficié mais plusieurs enquêtes
journalistiques ont montré que l'argent
de ce fond Marianne avait été mal
utilisé notamment par deux associations
qui sont mises en cause d'abord l'Union
des sociétés d'éducation physique et de
préparation militaire qui a reçu
355000 euros 120000 euros ont servi à
salarié ces dirigeants et les contenus
publiés par cette association ont été
très peu consultés sur Internet l'autre
association qui est mise en cause
s'appelle reconstruire le commun à la
toucher 300.000 euros grâce au fond
Marianne et à la publié une vidéo à
caractère politique pendant la campagne
présidentielle notamment contre la
candidate Anne Hidalgo la semaine
dernière le parquet national financier a
ouvert une information judiciaire pour
détournement de fonds publics privilégal
d’intérêt à but de confiance et le Sénat
s'apprête donc à voter en faveur d'une
commission d'enquête sur cette affaire
écoutez celui qui en sera le rapporteur
le sénateur Jean-François écoutez-le sur
le travail que va mener cette commission
d'enquête nous avons besoin de
comprendre de quelle manière à l'issue
d'un événement dramatique je le rappelle
l'assassinat barbare de Samuel Paty le
gouvernement par la voie d'une ministre
avait pris des décisions créant un fond
Marianne aujourd'hui certaines
informations ont été rendues publiques
et notamment sur l'utilisation de ces
fonds et bien nous allons procéder de
manière je le dis méthodique objectif
sereine
voilà un état d'esprit serein pour la
commission des finances qui aura
normalement les pouvoirs d'une
commission d'enquête et l'une des
questions qui sera posée ce sera la
responsabilité de la ministre qui a créé
et piloter ce fond mariage à savoir
Marlène Schiappa quand elle était
ministre en charge de la citoyenneté
marine Chapat qui est actuellement ce
défend contre les accusations de
certains adversaires politiques
accusations de favoritisme envers
certaines associations écoutez là elle
était sur notre plateau il y a deux
semaines je démentir aussi quelque chose
qui a été dit notamment par certains
responsables et les filles qui ont dit
que j'avais donné d'argent à mes amis
qui avaient du copinage ou du
favoritisme je ne suis amie avec aucun
lauréat du fond Marianne aucun pas un
pas un est mon proche ni personnellement
ni associer ni que sais-je contrairement
à ce que j'ai lu eux-mêmes l'ont démenti
mais après vous voyez à quel point ces
accusations sont difficiles à démentir
la commission enquête du Sénat devrait
commencer ses travaux à la fin du mois
de mai et aura trois mois pour rendre
ses conclusions Claude Raynal au vu des
documents que vous avez pu consulter
notamment en tant que président de la
commission des finances quelle question
se pose selon vous avant et bien le
début des travaux de la commission
d'enquête alors je parlerai des
questions et je parlerai de la procédure
si vous le voulez bien alors au niveau
des questions les choses sont assez
simples il y a-t-il eu une autre rôle
détournement d'argent public oui ou non
qui est-ce qui a eu des fautes dans le
suivi de cette opération ou du laxisme
du lycée allais il faut le définir qui
en est le responsable comment les
associations au départ avaient-elles été
choisie sur quel critères nous n'avons
pas de grille de critères voilà les
questions très simples qui se posent qui
vont permettre en avançant de se faire
une vision mais je voudrais insister sur
le deuxième point qui est le point de
procédure car le point que vous avez
indiqué sur cette commission d'enquête
c'est un point à date
et il faut bien regarder comment les
choses se déroulent d'ailleurs je
l'avais extrêmement bien précisé j'avais
fait une proposition suite à la
réception de documents que j'avais
demandé sur le fond mariage à l'issue de
quoi la commission des finances à
l'unanimité à voter pour une mission
d'information susceptible de se
transformer en mission d'enquête après
deux réunions l'une de la commission des
lois qui regarde la recevabilité et une
autre de la Conférence des présidents du
Sénat qui décident donc nous en sommes
là et nous aurons ce soir la Conférence
des Présidents et demain la commission
des lois et donc tant que ces deux
commissions ne sont pas prononcées je ne
prononce pas sur le lancement de la
commission d'enquête
à partir du moment où tout le monde est
d'accord non pour vous ça peut encore
transformer en commission d'enquête il y
a un élément nouveau c'est la saisie
l'ouverture d'enquête par le parquet
national financier et la question qui
est là c'est que vous savez que de
pouvoir ne peuvent pas s'occuper de la
même affaire donc si le judiciaire par
le parquet national financier comment
dire
soulève une série de questions un
certain nombre de sujets qui sont de
nature finalement à bloquer la
commission d'enquête celle-ci ne
s'ouvrira pas au moins tant que le PNF
travaille voilà donc il y a un sujet
encore qui est sur la table pour la
délimitation mais ça avait été chaque
fois qu'une commission enquête il y a un
sujet toujours avec le pénal le pénal
l'emporte si je puis dire sur les
commissions d'enquête parlementaires
donc si le PNF donc si nous
au niveau du Sénat et de manière tout à
fait en droit si je puis dire bon
endroit si nous considère que nous
n'avons plus les moyens d'avancer parce
que la façon dont le PNF
traite les accusations et de nature à
nous bloquer et bien ça sera bloqué au
moins le temps que le PNF fasse son
travail nous le serons mercredi mais
c'est votre avis est-ce que vous pensez
que l'ouverture de cette enquête par le
PNL va affaiblir votre commission
d'enquête parlementaire il y a un risque
il y a un risque il y a un risque mais
qu'il faut lever donc il y a un courrier
qui a été envoyé par mon collègue
président de la commission des lois au
à la chancellerie de manière à bien
préciser les choses mais il y a des
soupçons de détournement de fonds
publics très bien
abus de confiance prise illégal
d'intérêt très bien ce sont des sujets
de toute façon que nous aurions mis un
exergue mais pas traité ils revient
effectivement au juge de dire le droit
là et éventuellement de prononcer des
sanctions mais par contre il y a un
autre sujet qui est complexe c'est le
détournement par négligence de fonds
publics alors le détournement par
négligence fonds publics est-ce que ça
va jusqu'à
la comment dire le contrôle de toute la
chaîne
préalable avant si vous voulez la
désignation des associations à ce
moment-là et bien ça nous priverait
quasiment de moyens d'action c'est le
débat que nous aurons ce soir au Sénat
donc il y a pas un sujet c'est sans
surprise côté Sénat il y avait un accord
à 100% pour faire politiquement en tout
cas c'est sans surprise tout le monde
est d'accord politiquement tout le monde
est d'accord mais il y a un sujet
technique si je puis dire avec le PNF et
justement le point qui pourrait
intéresser votre enquête parlementaire
c'est cette négligence selon vous au vu
des premiers documents que vous avez pu
consulter il y a eu un manque de
contrôle de suivi peut-être même de
rigueur dans la sélection des
associations des associations on
comprendrez bien que je peux je ne me
lance pas dans des dans des sujets de
nature qui sont le fond finalement de la
commission donc si j'avais des idées
préconçues sur le sujet si vous voulez
ce ne serait pas souhaitable donc par
contre je relève que le PNF lui site
nommément cette voilà ce problème ce
sujet donc
dès l'instant où il le site ça va être
déjà dit que tout ce que nous avons dit
jusqu'ici se révèle exact sinon le PNF
se saisirait pas du fond Marianne mais
juste pour qu'on soit bien clair que
vous dites au vu de l'ouverture de cette
enquête par le PNF il vaut peut-être
mieux qu'on attende avant de faire cette
commission d'enquête pour que notre
travail soit plus efficace ou est-ce que
vous pensez que vous pourrez réussir à
mener un travail efficace en parallèle
est-ce que c'est pas le bon moment
finalement d'ouvrir cette commission
d'enquête pour vous
moi je pense tout à fait qu'il aurait
été plutôt souhaitable d'avoir en un
mois un mois et demi au final avant
l'été d'avoir les conclusions de la
commission d'enquête sénatoriale avant
que le PNF ouvre sa propre enquête de
nature donc judiciaire qui sont deux
choses à la fois
concomitante et à la fois séparés sur
les objectifs c'est pas de même nature
on peut tout à fait d'ailleurs comment
dire commettre une faute sur un des
aspects et pas sur l'autre c'est à dire
on peut tout à fait dire la commission
d'enquête pourrait par exemple montrer
des dysfonctionnements d'une chaîne de
décision sans que pour autant ça soit de
nature judiciaire vous voyez donc si
vous me demandez mon avis j'aurais
souhaité que nous passions en premier je
l'espère encore nous allons débattre et
nous verrons comment on doit comprendre
cette ouverture judiciaire sur les
vidéos à caractère politique qui ont été
publiés par l'une des associations
pendant la campagne présidentielle ça ça
peut rester dans votre chambre dans
votre chambre d'investigation pour
l'instant tout est cité quasiment par le
PNF
donc je dans préjugue pas la commission
des lois doit se prononcer nous verrons
bien je lui fais confiance pour trouver
pour dire les choses que telles qu'elles
sont en lien avec la chancellerie et
peut-être une dernière question sur
Marlène Schiappa vu qu'elle est mise en
cause par cette affaire et qu'elle est
actuellement ministre en charge du
secteur associatif et ce qu'elle peut
rester en poste
ça m'appartient pas de dire voilà de
prononcer des des voilà la ministre est
mise en cause à un titre aujourd'hui
c'est en tant que ayant créé le fond
d'une part et au titre de sa direction
de son administration voilà où nous en
sommes aujourd'hui et il ne m'appartient
pas de d'aller au-delà pour l'instant si
la commission d'enquête se met en place
c'est telle que vous additionnerez en
premier Marlène Chabat je crois pas qui
d'abord je crois pas je pense que c'est
d'abord le secrétaire général
qui est en charge finalement du faux
mariage voilà administrativement et qui
doit nous dire d'abord ce qui s'est
passé voilà
plutôt vers la fin
merci Alex à tout à l'heure à tout à
l'heure évidemment dans le club on
parlera de la délinquance rurale avec
vous on va voir l'actualité dans votre
région Occitanie maintenant Claude
Raynal on va à Montpellier on retrouve
Olivier Biscaye bonjour Olivier merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous Olivier
directeur de la rédaction du Midi Libre
et avec vous on va parler de
l'initiative cette initiative de la
présidente de la région occitanique à
rodelga d'organiser les premières
rencontres des maires d'Occitanie
Olivier oui les premiers rencontres
d'Occitanie en deux temps aujourd'hui à
Montpellier demain à Toulouse la
présidente de la région Carol Belga a
invité les 4500 maires à aborder les les
priorités d'action et les préoccupations
au quotidien elle souhaite dans le
moment de crise sociale dit-elle crise
aussi de vocation puisque de nombreux
maires ont démissionné et bien évoquer
avec eux et avec elle les différents
projets les différentes problématiques
et surtout l'accompagnement de la région
au quotidien donc ce sont des premières
rencontres ici organisées en Occitanie à
Montpellier et
à Toulouse il y aura bien sûr les
présents intercommunalité et quelques
élus départementaux et régionaux qui
seront qui s'y présents peut-être dans
ce cadre Oriane une question à Claude
Raynal qui est certes sénateurs de la
Haute-Garonne mais vous avez été aussi
maire de tournesfeuille est-ce que vous
seriez allé à ce rendez-vous organisé
par Carole Delga ce matin à Montpellier
demain à Toulouse est-ce que c'est une
bonne idée bien entendu c'est toujours
une bonne idée surtout quand on voit
comment éventuellement le président de
la République s'y prend c'est toujours
une bonne idée pour un président une
présidente de région de réunir les
maires qui sont effectivement des
acteurs avec lesquels la région
travaille régulièrement de les réunir à
la fois pour présenter peut-être les
nouvelles politiques de la région au
niveau projet et puis les réunir aussi
pour les écouter donc bien sûr toujours
très favorable à ce type de dialogue qui
soit régional qui soit départementale la
région est un élément important des
politiques finalement municipales
avec les maires on dit beaucoup que
Carole Delga souhaite parfaire son son
ambitieux elle est sur une une ambition
présidentielle du temps elle s'en défend
mais tout tout participe de cette
construction il voyait vous une ambition
présidentielle dans ce rendez-vous des
maires bah si vous voulez
si tout sujet doit prêter à quel est
l'objectif final etc je crois que
l'objectif simple il est tout à fait
clair et il pose pas de difficultés
voilà après pour le reste c'est autre
chose et je vous laisse ces supputations
qui vous permettez Claude rénal Carole
Delga indique dans dans nos colonnes
qu'elle ne souhaite pas être soumise aux
insoumis enfin en traduction elle
souhaite faire cavalier seul finalement
or de la nuque pourtant une nouvelle
gauche un nouveau parti socialiste quel
regard portez-vous sur cette ambition
sur cette stratégie les autres stratégie
ne m'a pas convaincu jusqu'à présent en
tout cas voilà il y a eu je le rappelle
des candidats dissidents présentés aux
dernières législatives on peut dire que
c'était plutôt un flop et que ce n'est
pas la méthode qu'il fallait choisir à
ce moment-là donc
région sauf pour Martine Froget dans
votre région ça peut être un flop c'est
autre chose d'abord c'est entre deux
listes de gauche donc le sujet à
l'époque c'était pas entre de liste de
gauche c'était entre un candidat de
gauche et le rassemblement national
rappelons les choses comme elles sont
donc entre deux listes de gauche qui est
un choix par les par les les citoyens
très bien bon voilà ça reste une
personnalité de gauche qui est élue
voilà donc ça comment dire c'est
différent non à l'époque c'était un
enjeu qui était majeur c'était la lutte
contre le rassemblement national et chez
nous le rassemblement national vous le
savez a marqué des points avec beaucoup
d'élus par rapport à ce qu'il y avait
traditionnellement dans cette région et
donc je pense que dans ces moments-là il
faut faire comme elle dirait d'ailleurs
elle-même il faut faire Pâques
faire Pâques faire cohérence mais pour
autant elle a des points de désaccord
majeurs avec Olivier Faure et avec
certains dirigeants du Parti socialiste
elle a probablement raison selon vous de
porter une autre voie et puis on verra
en 2027 c'est ce que vous dites aussi
non mais écoutez tout militant
socialiste moi je suis au mieux parti
social depuis 40 ans j'ai toujours été
j'ai très souvent été minoritaire
j'étais rocardien dans un espace
mitterrandiste j'aime autant vous dire
que c'était un peu plus violent à
l'époque donc les piliers des positions
et des nuances différentes bien entendu
elles doivent s'exprimer bien entendu et
elle suite de ça il faut trouver des
stratégies communes et avancer ensemble
elles peuvent continuer à cohabiter au
sein du PS et deux lignes qui sont si
différentes
je vous rappelais alors peut-être c'est
un peu ancien maintenant mais le
regardisme contre le mitterrandisme ce
qu'on appelait la première gauche contre
la deuxième gauche rocardienne
j'aime autant vous dire qu'il y a des
documents épais comme au plafond qui
montre les différences qui avaient avec
nous ou avec d'autres avec Jean-Pierre
Chevènement on avait des débats
extrêmement dur mais sur sur le fond et
donc ce qui compte aujourd'hui c'est
plus une
UPS etc c'est de définir des éléments de
fond qui parlent à nous électeurs et qui
répondent aux angoisses des électeurs en
France voilà le sujet merci Olivier un
mot sur votre une Olivier la une du Midi
Libre aujourd'hui c'est Michel Cordesse
Roland Marci pour beaucoup de Français à
la une du Midi Libre Olivier oui
absolument Roland merci Michel corde qui
vivait à grabel c'est qui s'est suicidé
en fin de semaine on est revenu avec les
habitants les citoyens les associations
qui l'ont qui l'ont bien connu et qui
racontent leur Roland merci
et c'est à dire aujourd'hui dans le Midi
Libre merci beaucoup Olivier Biscaye
merci d'avoir été avec nous et merci
Claude Raynald d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première demi-heure